Speaker 1: All right, a couple of quick stories I
didn't want to miss today. There are people on the
right going absolutely crazy because DirecTV, the
satellite television provider, has announced that
they are going to be dropping 08 and One America
news from their channel lineup at a point in the
near future. Now, if you don't remember and you've
got Fox News, which is right wing corporate,
you've got Newsmax, which is slightly less
corporate and slightly crazier. And then you've
got OANN, which is slightly less corporate than
Newsmax and even more insane than Newsmax. It is a
trash just pond scum type channel, and DirecTV
has announced that they are going to be dropping
the channel DirecTV to drop one America News
Network. As reported by NPR, DirecTV will be
dropping the channel in a surprise move, sure to
deal a massive blow to the network that rose to
prominence during Trump's presidency. Bloomberg
reported that satellite TV provider DirecTV
notified the owner of 0& Herring Networks Inc that
it would no care no longer carry the company's two
channels when their contract expires. The
other channel, a wealth of entertainment,
dubs itself a lifestyle channel featuring
luxury goods. I didn't even know that existed.
DirecTV said it made the decision
following a routine internal review,
a DirecTV spokesperson told NPR. The company looks
at many factors in terms of whether to renew. And
one question is, does the programing appeal to
a broad enough base of customers given increased
programing costs and competition for consumers?
DirecTV says it's basically a business decision
that was not in the best interests of
DirecTV. AT&T is a majority owner of DirecTV.
And you might remember we covered this when it
broke. AT&T has been facing calls to drop OANN
over its support of conspiracy theories. DirecTV
spokesman declined to comment on whether Owen's
editorial policies were a factor.
Rand Paul, the Republican senator,
he I guess, had DirecTV Now. Oftentimes people
who have DirecTV, I don't want to say. Sometimes
when people have DirecTV or Dish, it's because
they live in a rural area without cable. I don't
think that applies to Rand Paul, but Rand Paul
says he had DirecTV. He says he's canceling it
because they have dropped. They are dropping OAS.
And he says, why give money to people who hate us?
So I guess supporting the exact
type of boycotts that he often
advocates against? And then Donald Trump, during
his rally in Arizona over the weekend, also
alluded to the same thing. And he says the channel
was threatened by woke executives at AT&T. And
he also says, boycott AT&T. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: But you know what? One America news has
done a great job, and here's the story What just
happened? The woke executives? I don't know what
the hell they're doing. They have so much debt.
AT&T is a company that is in serious trouble,
and they need AT&T and AT&T
saying that they may no longer
agree to carry this network. That's doing very
well. You know why? Because people told them
not to do it. So maybe what we should do is not
use AT&T, you know, if we did, if we did what
they do to Republican companies, we would have
no difficulty. We just don't do it. It seems like
not nice, right? But they're not nice. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I mean, listen, this is all again,
their backwards version of freedom, and it's
going to come up in the next segment as well.
We talked about it at the top of the show. They
say let businesses do whatever they want. They
say these woke boycotts are a bad thing. They
say we shouldn't regulate businesses unless
and then all of a sudden DirecTV makes a business
decision, maybe influenced by AT&T also wanting
it made as a business decision. And now all of a
sudden they go crazy and they say it's suppression
of speech and they say all these different
things. No one has a right to be on DirecTV.
We're on DirecTV. The David Pakman show airs on a
channel called Free Speech TV, and it's on DirecTV
and Dish Network at any time. Free speech TV could
tell us we're not going to carry the show anymore,
and DirecTV or Dish could tell free speech TV.
We're not going to carry the channel anymore.
It's not a First Amendment issue. It's completely
legal. It's this backwards version of freedom that
they seem to only care about when it's convenient
for them. And then if it's no longer convenient,
it goes out the window. And the next story, quite
frankly, is another example of that as well.